hello everyone
hi everyone
so thank you very much for joining this
session uh so today we will be talking
about large language models and in
particular about a common Journey on
developing large language models and we
will be illustrating that with my
colleague Miguel uh with a work that we
have been doing at Nvidia on training
large-scale language model for Spanish
and French language models so next
please
so I think we can skip the introduction
so I will hang it to you now Miguel
thank you everybody for joining us so
this slide is basically a joke nonsense
because this is how people usually
perceives training a large language
model actually all the things that are
here almost all of them are using this
talk but they are hiding under with the
Frameworks so the complexity is much
lower and in this set image what we
would like to highlight that it is
pretty simple to make these things work
we have attached the code to the slides
of of each of the steps that we perform
in case you would like to replicate that
in your systems
so what are we talking about we'll talk
about a trip it was once Main and I was
talking as many times and we said why
don't we prepare something in our local
languages in Spanish and French why
don't we try to do that in our expert
time actually we have some allocate time
allocated for experiment and we decided
to
to to allocate that time for this
exercise so we move from data
preparation to preaching a language
model to use it on other tasks like
translation q a and summarization to
finally deploy that into production and
and while learning this we we will
explain a few things why huge models are
important how are we using this language
modeling a different way that we used to
use how we can train the modeling a
Distributive way how we can query that
in additional way in order to have a
couple of language models Mimi in France
I mean in Spanish
so natural language processing itself is
a discipline that lets you do things
with a human text and perform multiple
tasks such as sentiment analysis code
generation q a summarization and a few
other tasks and this that is what we are
going to learn to do today
but before that I would like to to
mention a couple of things first of all
someone noticed that the bigger the
model are the bigger the data sets are
the better the performance of the
language model is actually that can be
extended to any discipline basically in
any deep neural network if you make it
bigger and you train it with more data
it will convert faster which is really
interesting even if it is bigger and
also it will it will uh give you better
results in specifically for NLP we
started using a new architecture the
Transformers one which basically
overcomes some issues or or problems
that other approaches had like running
ants or STM basically by making use of
the attention mechanism which is a way
to let the neural network not forget
things in long sentences we will have a
huge increase of performance of these
models it is well worth to mention that
this architecture has already been is
being currently used on many other
domains computer vision automatic speed
recognition United models and
reinforcement learning so it it looks
like like it is a very good one which
also scales really good which fits the
previous result that the bigger the
model is and the bigger data set is the
whether the overall performances
so and we have seen that basically in
the last two years the the the size of
the models using a Transformer
architecture has increased 275 times
just to give you some context alexnet
was only a few Millions parameters 10
years later we are talking about
530 billion parameters that's a huge
jump and it can only be supported by a
specific hardware and also a specific
architectures like Transformers and
that's why we use it
and and there is a very interesting
thing that we are moving from a paradigm
which is training a language model that
we'll see was starting a few seconds I'm
fine-tuning it to retrain that on a
specific data set to make it work a
specific task we are moving from that
Paradigm that has it called some pros to
a different one where we will just train
a single language model and then we will
query it basically feeding input data in
a way that it will produce answers that
corresponds to a specific questions so
for instance we have a tasks that can be
considered sentiment analysis this is a
language model a language model let's
let's start by that it's just a a neural
network where you you fit some input
text for instance you feed my name is
Miguel and and you ask them to complete
a sentence with a maximum of token or
until it considers that it has finished
so in this exam sample that we are
saying to any other memories question
would you say this this movie review is
positive or negative and then we add a
movie review I love that movie and we
asked the neural network to complete
that that sentence and it will say that
it is a negative so it is performing a
scientific analysis task but it hasn't
been trained on that task and that is
really really an interesting behavior
and actually it behaves really really
well by following that pattern which is
basically in the input making a that's
description some examples we can add
some examples of the tasks that we want
to perform in this example is translate
English to French we have an English
word equivalent in French and then we
add another English word cheese and we
explained that the language model
produces the translation because somehow
it has not only learned the the syntax
of of the language but it also has some
knowledge based on that huge Corpus we
have used to train playing our language
model so in this case hopefully it
returns from Ash which is a French word
for cheese and we can do that in a zero
shot without examples and just the test
description with a one shot or with
future example which is basically adding
a few examples the great news is that we
can get to a state-of-the-art results by
only using a few examples basically with
a big enough model and only 10 to the
one so 10 examples we can get to a state
of the results that's a huge say a
change in the Paradigm because we don't
need labeled data sets to train the
language model for a specific task we
are using the language model as it is
and we're just querying it in a very
clever way
meeting I think we'll mention a bit more
about this later so that is what we are
using and here it's an example let me
skip the video because we don't have
that much time but basically we we feed
some some examples English to French and
we expect that the language model would
translate this sentence from English to
French we ask the language model to use
32 tokens in the answer and if we jump
here
it actually Returns the answer it says
well the the the the the French sentence
for this English English sentence and it
is really really good but once again the
the magical thing is that we haven't had
an English to French
data set specific for translation it's
very likely that this language model in
its Corpus has lots of examples of
English and French State and it has done
the relationship itself and that's
fantastic and and it knows that it is
translating because we guide it by
providing up front and input sentence
that looks like English and French
examples
so how to do this so this is our trip
from data preparation training a
language model quoting it in a clever
way the one that we have mentioned right
now and then deployed to production and
we did that in only three weeks in our
spare time because we wanted to to tell
the people that it is easy if Miguel can
do it anyone can do it that is the key
message don't forget that okay so and
and then you have the code to to do that
so for data preparation we use an open
source Corpus as orcas Oscar which is a
multilingual data set we focus on the
French and Spanish parts of that data
set and we perform these steps you can
see here in the slides the link to the
code that we use for each of the spit we
perform texted application language
filtering in general cleaning and
blacklisting let's go into those details
text duplication is basically when you
use a core boost that has been taken
from internet for instance the chances
are that the the sentence this school
happens lots a lot of time maybe we
don't need so many examples of this
school with one or it just works so
Texas duplication basically removes the
the duplicated sentence in your Corpus
to to to make it a training faster and
in a more efficient way
language filtering is in this kind of
data sets the chances are that even if
it is classified like Spanish someone
introduced a
Italian sentence or an English sentence
or maybe a JavaScript or HTML so we need
to make sure that if we want to produce
a pure Spanish that has a language model
or a French language model we only use
examples in Spanish and inference
language filter and step what it does it
uses a neural network to analyze the the
each of the sentences um and try to
predict if the sentence is Spanish or
French and if not just remove it from
our from our data set then we have the
general cleaning step which is basically
uh this even if these Corpus are very
clean usually sometimes they have
unexpected elements like JavaScript or
HTML or other things we just need to get
rid of them because we would light in
this exercise to produce human readable
text so we are not expecting that to
convert from from Spanish to to python
we just want to to be able to perform
tasks that are Spanish or French speaker
would do and then the blacklisting this
is just an exercise because we will like
or maybe some people would like to but
we wanted to avoid our models to be rude
to produce bad words uh and or hate
messages so we performed some techniques
one of them was to remove the documents
with at least two blacklisted terms so
basically we just selected
um some words that does that are not
really good ones and and we remove any
sentence that had at least a couple of
them why at least a couple of them
because some words in our languages can
have multiple meanings and some means
can be valid and cannot be rude or
cannot be something that we wouldn't
like the the language models to produce
so we decided that silly logic it can be
done during the training or it can be
done as a post-processing step we
decided to do that doing the training
but the other alternative also works and
we can do both so just some figures for
the text duplication exercise in in a
real world server it tooks around 12
hours each
okay I need to reduce the original data
set from to half more or less from 282
gigabytes to 117 gigabytes so we are
saving time because we are reducing some
amount and we also did a very important
task which is the language models do not
really have text as input parameter
under the hood what they are sorry under
the hood what they have is a vectors of
numeric vectors so we need to to to to
let those numeric factors that is the
tokenizing a step we use a tokenizer and
and it just takes 45 minutes to convert
the text here to a set of of ideas which
is a numerical representation of our
words
um finally we perform one more task
which is to convert our data set that
was originally in Json L files to
to uh binary format and that is just
because of we will reuse those sentences
multiple times and we want a very
efficient way to load them and to and to
have them into memory so it is well
worth this this time consuming task
which is converting to a map format but
we need to do that hopefully all the
code is here and you can see the the
command that we need to to do that is
pretty straightforward and I think that
with that I can give the word to Marian
that will explain in detail with the
next step that we did thank you Maria
okay thank you very much Miguel so now
let's Deep dive into training the
language model and in particular into
1.7 billion language model that we
trained with together with Miguel so 1.7
billion is already big right but uh how
big is that actually and let's have a
look at that so next please
okay here we go so let's actually start
by doing some math so for training a 1.7
billion parameter model so if we
consider a training in fp16 mode right
so that means that the weights and the
gradients are represented in fp60 and if
we consider using like one of the most
popular optimizers today that we are
using or it's equivalent like atom
Optimizer so it will store 12 bytes per
weight so let's do the math so this
model during the training will take
about 25 gigabytes and this is
um not taken into account the data the
feature maps that are trained actually
during the training right so but if you
have a 16 gigabyte of memory in your GPU
you cannot fit this model into into that
GPU so as you can see so here as we
scale those language models so we need
to actually develop some techniques to
distribute those models so next please
yeah
here we go so there are plenty of
strategies today with very different
implementations of distributed training
of neural network and among which we can
introduce the what we call the data
parallel or the model parallel so so for
the data parallel that you can see here
on the left so when performing data
distribution so like what we do is we
copy the same model into different gpus
and each GPU is going to actually
process different chunks of the data and
then communicate the gradients and this
will have a cost actually of a gradient
Exchange in this case for model
distribution in this case so the model
itself is split into different gpus and
this will allow to actually scale to
larger models that will not fit to one
GPU and this is the case for example for
the 1.7 billion if we use a small GPU
um but it will have some cost in in
future map Exchange in this case and we
do actually have different type of model
distribution I can like present the
pipeline parallel for example
distribution it consists on splitting
sequentially the the model let's say
layer 0 1 2 3 of our neural network into
GPU zero four five six into GPU one and
so on and the terms are parallel
distribution that actually split each
layer into different gpus and this will
will have some cost in this case so
while we are training those a very large
neural networks so we have to choose the
distribution techniques according to the
hardware configuration that we are
having because so we can have different
type of costs in terms of communication
actually according to the hardware
infrastructure okay next please
okay so with Miguel so we trained the
model using Nvidia Library called
megatronal M on several digix1 servers
so each server is composed by eight uh
V100 gpus with 32 gigabytes so Mega
Channel m is an Nvidia open source
library for training Transformer based
neural network and it integrates
actually different distribution
strategies such as the tonsil parallel
and the pipeline parallel and so on so
on the top you can see the architecture
of the model that we have been using and
some hyper parameters that we we use for
the French and the Spanish model so
those are for your reference and that
those those hyper parameters can be used
as a kind of starting point if you want
to start experimenting
so
um uh um yes and what we have been doing
also for the training is we distributed
our model using tensor parallel equal to
two and use the rest of the the the the
resources for the pipe for the data
distribution and you can see the
training performance actually here
measured by the perplexity metrics that
you can see here yes okay so lower is
better
and actually the flexibility of the
implementation of megatronal M allowed
us to run the training according to the
resources that we had available so we
had several training rounds of eight
hours each uh with the of resources that
we can allocate and we used for each
round the resources that we had from two
notes to 16 nodes so the this training
in total took us about five uh thousand
uh GPU hours V100 GPU hours uh per per
model okay so let's have a look at the
results
next okay so here you can see some
examples of text generated by the French
language model so on the left the input
prompt and on the right the text that
was generated by the French language
model so the model is not only
generating
grammatically and semantically
consistent text but it was also able to
contextualize
um the generated sentences according to
the input itself so for example here
the politic context with the president
Emmanuel Macar about the climate change
or about the physics with the relativity
Theory and so on uh next please I think
we have some some also some some
examples for the Spanish model here
so those are for for your reference um
if you want to have a look okay so now
let's have a look at the downstream test
so we are uh so the question now is like
how to apply those large language models
for to solve a specific NLP task so
first we can continue training the
language model using label data set for
Downstream tasks and this is something
that we know very well for encoder based
language models such as bird for example
where we fine-tune the classifier layers
that we add on top of the language model
for gpt-like models we can continue
training further with the next token
generation on label data set in this
case but this is not very efficient and
very costly actually if you want to
fine-tune those models and for large
scale language models so um that showed
actually very good results in few short
mode that Miguel introduced earlier so
to generate the answer what we can do is
we can just simply query the language
bundle by formulating the NRP test
description so such as you know like
translate from English to French or
something like that and to give some
examples if you want to be on few short
mode
um so so
you have some examples here on the left
on some type of prompts that we need to
engineer in order to ask the to describe
the the tasks that for instance for
sentiment analysis I love this movie by
giving us input uh the the document and
would say like this would you say that
this movie is uh positive or negative
you know and and ask the model to to
predict actually the Y here for example
however actually similarly to what we
have been experimenting actually on the
French and the Spanish language model so
several studies showed that the those
models are very very sensitive to the
way we are engineering those prompts
sometimes by changing actually some
terms in in the prompt itself let's say
for example saying
um X was created by or it is created by
uh would actually give you different
accuracies of the model so those model
those are very very sensitive to the way
we are describing the task and the
recent area of research focuses on new
techniques called prompt learning
techniques so let's have a look at that
next please
here we go so prompt learning techniques
to just optimizing the task description
in a continuous space so instead of
Designing The Prompt in the word space
or the token space so we are actually
optimizing the task description in the
continuous space so it uses actually
prompt encoder showed here in the in
this image in red here a train to
generate the task representation in a
supervised way so in this case The
Prompt token is tuned for different
tasks why the large language model is
Frozen that you can see here in blue and
can be used for different tasks and
currently prompt tuning techniques are
one of the most promising research topic
actually in large language models okay
next
and at Nvidia actually so we have a
library called Nemo an open source
Library where we recently integrated
prompt tune in implementation so to do
so so Nemo provides some tools to
convert Megatron LM checkpoints to Nemo
and some examples from prompt tune in
and P tuning so those are some of the
examples that you can have a look at so
we put the link here okay
next
all right so so we trained the model we
fine tune it or we prompt learn it so
now how we apply so and we are happy
with the performance of those models now
how to deploy those models into
production so let's have a look next
please
and let's start actually considering the
memory footprint the memory requirement
for more such models let's take for
example the gpt3 with 175 billion
parameter model so 175 billion parameter
model in fp16 takes two bytes per weight
and this would actually take about 325
gigabytes in of memory footprint so this
is really a lot for the interference and
there are some techniques to reduce the
memory footprint such as pruning or
quantization so next please so let's say
for example if we prune half of the
weights by using techniques like
structured sparsity for example so the
memory footprint of this neural network
would drop to from 325 to 162 gigabytes
and next you can see also by using some
other techniques so next Miguel
um such as quantization for example
um uh we can drop actually the the
memory footprint to um about 80 81
gigabytes here so so quantization
basically we take a model that is
trained in fp32 or fp16 and find a
mapping to represent each value in lower
precision and here in this case in int 8
and by by quantizing into in eight for
example so we can have we can really
reduce the the memory footprint our of
our model
okay next please okay so the tools
several tools can be used for efficient
model deployment so at Nvidia we have
two tools that can be used for large
language models such as tonsor RT and
faster Transformer in order to optimize
the model so we will see some features
in the in the next slide and then so we
we can use Triton inference server to
deploy those models into production so
Triton allows to
multiple features such as Dynamic
patching model and sampling concurrent
model and it supports many different
type of models such as on NX tonsority
or faster Transformer execution backend
okay next
okay so as discussed so we mentioned
that we do we can optimize the neural
network itself using two different
libraries tanzarity or faster
Transformer
um so however there are some differences
between those two libraries so for
instance thumbs RT does not support out
of the box uh model distribution so
model parallelism while faster
Transformer supports Pipeline and tensor
parallel out of the box a faster
Transformer is limited to
um a short list I would say of
Transformer models why tonsority
supports a variety of neural network not
just Transformer model but also other
type of neural network like
convolutional neural network and so on
and finally faster Transformer offers
the faster inference for gpt-like models
okay
next please
all right so okay in our process for the
French and Spanish model so we use
faster Transformer to optimize the model
so first we needed to convert the
pytorch checkpoint that we trained with
Megatron 11 to faster Transformer and
here you have an example on the top left
actually from Megatron LM Library
showing how you can convert actually
that so we will simply need to specify
the tensor parallel mode used used
during the training in our case we train
the model using pipe tensor parallel
equal to two sorry and we need to
provide also the targeted the model
distribution that we want to have at the
inference time so let's say for example
8 or 2 or 4 or like how we would like to
to to to distribute the model
uh so and then after after the
optimizing the model we can use faster
Transformer back end of Triton inference
server to launch the server okay so
faster Transformer provides also a text
generation tool and an example is showed
in the left button here and we will be
actually showing that in the demo next
okay so again we're running off time by
the way yes okay so let me okay so let
me move it very very fast so here in
this demo showing we are showing several
inference
um configurations for the French model
and we are giving as input actually a
like a prompt
francaise and generate in this next
token which is Will supposed to be
liberte and we can actually Benchmark
different type of distribution different
type of interference with fp16 and also
um we're using pipeline parallel or
tonsil parallel we can see the GPU
utilization here using one or two gpus
depending on the distribution that we
are using here okay so let's go very
quickly to the conclusion
okay so in this journey we use publicly
available data sets and codes so we hope
that we were able to demystify the
development of large language models so
that anyone actually who wants to tackle
that problem can uh get guidance and
start know where to start and honestly
once we know how to do it once we can
improve this entire plus process
customize the model the hyper parameters
the data set quality we can scale to
larger models and so on okay so we can
just move on to next please go move on
again
all right so from Nvidia perspective we
are actively working on this field so we
have the hardware and also the software
solutions for efficiently training and
deploying large language models so I
would like to highlight the Nemo
Megatron software that offers a
ready-to-use tools for developing uh
large GPT and T5 like language models
and it provides recipes for several
scales of models and also tools for
automatic research for the best hyper
parameters and it supports also
deployment with faster Transformer so
Nemo Megatron is now in open Beta so if
you are interested please apply income
and with that I think we we can stop
here thank you very much
okay
thank you all I'm not sure if we have
thanks time for any questions or
thanks Miguel thanks Miriam so we do
have a question by switlana and she's
saying what's about the use of
Triton
yeah it threaten itself is it's a a an
open source tool from Nvidia that lets
you deploy any type of titular Network
in production and it also runs those
neural networks either on CPUs on gpus
so why do we use it because it has lots
of features for it instantly lets you do
modern assembling which means you can
concatenate the out output of a model
and feed it as the input of an X1 is
less you do this or like a automatic
button request you have a certain
threshold I mean your application should
provide a reply before than 300
milliseconds and it will group all the
requests guaranteeing that all the
clients will have that answer in that
threshold and that's really interesting
because it maximizes the use of the gpus
therefore you need to use less gpus in
production to serve your customers and
those are just a couple of examples of
the of the use of threat on influence
server